depuis les hôpitaux ou craignant les
médecins multiplie les alertes des
enfants blessés parfois tués et souvent
traumatisés comme ceux de natalia
réfugier dans le métro à kiev
le soldat a dit courez vite c'était très
effrayant le plus petit mais fils cours
et il criait plus vite plus vite on nous
tire dessus on ne va pas survivre et
nous sommes venus ici maintenant mon
enfant a peur de sortir il pleure tout
le temps maman pas la nuit mon fils aîné
a crié dans la nuit maman à l'abri
beaucoup de ces enfants sont contraints
de quitter l'ukraine dans des conditions
éprouvantes plusieurs jours de route et
des heures de marche avant de pouvoir
être mise à l'abri sur leur parcours les
équipes de l'unicef tente d'apporter le
nécessaire aux familles sur le chemin de
l'exil la première chose c'est le
traitement du traumatisme des enfants
c'est essentiel de le faire tout de
suite nous avons des psychologues qui
sont habitués à ce genre de situation et
qui crée des conditions de protection
autour de ce point bleu il ya des
espaces ludiques pour pour les enfants
et il ya aussi bien sûr distributions de
nourriture également et de soins
d'hygiène parce qu'il faut des
couches-culottes imaginé trois jours de
voitures sans couches culottes avec des
bébés il faut des lingettes il faut donc
du matériel d'hygiène et de plus plus on
aura d'enfants sur les routes plus il
faudra s'occuper de cet aspect très
important aux manies moldavie pologne
hongrie slovaquie et république tchèque
autant de pays où ces jeunes victimes de
guerre tente de trouver refuge
sur le million et demi d'ukrainiens en
exil on estime que plus de la moitié
serait des enfants pour leur venir en
aide l'unicef a lancé jeudi dernier un
appel au don de 400 millions d'euros